[Music]  my name is Lemony Snicket it is I Count  Olaf and I find myself in all of my  glories what can only be described as a  series golden opportunities unfortunate  events drawing so close to fruition  mercifully to a close unfortunately we  started somewhat predictably at the  beginning I have some very bad news for  you children your home was destroyed and  your orphans now now after so many  misleading appearances brilliant  performances The Tortoise fires  fortunate coincidences unreasonable  behaviors learning experiences close  calls near misses and dreary weather  conditions all will be revealed the fate  of the Baudelaires  and the truth behind the letters VFD  because dear viewer count Olaf fans  we're almost to the end  fortunately unfortunately  [Music]  you